Mexico City home to 20 million people
most of them Catholics the church
forbids any dealings with witchcraft
saying it's the work of the devil
but for many Mexicans the allure of
magic both good and evil is irresistible
believers find the tools of witchcraft
at the Senora witches market a pro
Caribbean anthropologist Anthony
zabaleta has studied the market for 25
years in every cranny of this maze bruja
or witch doctors peddle their cures it's
a market for even the most gruesome
wares along with goods the market
provides services in back rooms behind
the stalls nearly anything is possible
spells can be cast or lifted customers
can have their spirits cleanse or engage
in satanic rites it's all here
curses fly powered by wing of bat and
tongue of pig witches bind hexes in
black ribbon ready for burial in a human
grave curses like these are all too
familiar to doctor zabaleta
as part of his research zabaleta has
been studying with alberto salinas a
healer who's come all the way from Texas
Alberto is here to restock his hex
fighting kit
believe in witchcraft was just an
abstract idea for doctors a Valletta
until he had his own life-changing
encounter with black magic Zabaleta was
traveling with alberto and other healers
on a mission what we found and what we
saw that day was just unbelievable in 30
years of research field research into
Leucadia including Diddy's Mullen I had
never encountered anything like that and
probably never will again they came to a
site where black magic was rumored to
take place doctors a Valletta videotaped
the events that followed showed up here
what is it all there oh my god
the healers had come upon nearly a
hundred objects buried as part of a
hexing ritual oh my God look at that
that's unbelievable I'll hold it up for
me my god this is casting a spell over
someone this is they have that card
except somebody huge to clean themselves
so they put some I belong another person
that they want to cast a spell over this
is a monster it is black magic is it
evil
just the the sense and the feeling that
I had of the the the people men women
children who were captured and so to
speak in those objects that are intended
to Daz to to break up marriages or break
up relationships or to bring people
together or more nefariously to kill
people and in people's lives there was a
horrible thing the healers felt they had
to take action and quickly for Alberto
the mission suddenly turned extremely
dangerous when you break spells and evil
spirits are concerned you are in danger
you're going into somebody's territory
somebody's domain it's obviously these
people happen to find out that you've
gone and destroyed something they've
done and they may try to do something to
you
I became physically I became I was ill
and everybody felt badly in one way or
another with so much evil concentrated
in one place
the healers felt their spirits were in
jeopardy doctors a Valletta suspended
his disbelief and agreed to be cleansed
Olympia to use the Spanish word ritual
sweeping and a cleansing to have
whatever might have attached itself to
us to take it off of us and hence to
make us whole and put us back together
his experience that day in that place
pushed aside science and challenged his
beliefs the effect where the real or
imagined was was very real on me and of
course an imagined effect or
psychologically and emotionally induced
a fact that produces physiological
change is valid and it's real but I've
seen many things that I simply cannot
explain
dr. Zabaleta story is not uncommon
science doesn't always conquer the
supernatural and for those who believe
witchcraft is all too real